Model building is a way to understand phenomena that are often complex and
a result of multiple interactions.
It is seldom possible to to clearly write down mathematical formulas that can
describe the phenomena at all scales and complexities.
Moreover, many phenomena can be repetitive or
periodic with a pattern that we can identify.
While other phenomena can be non-periodic, unusual, and anomalous.
We will in this lesson look at some simple ways we can model phenomena.
It is often a matter of experimenting with different techniques to
understand what works best.
The goal in this lesson is to get you to start
thinking iteratively through asking questions and making models.
We also want you to start thinking in terms of probabilities.
Given that you have already had some background in machine learning,
we will choose for an example non-parametric statistical models.
The techniques we illustrate should carry over to parametric models,
mathematical models, and machine learning models.
We invite you to try these other models that we will not have a chance
to explore in this lesson by using the methods that we demonstrate here.
So, follow along.